so for the second time in a month the
media experienced a reverse Christmas
expecting a pony and getting punched in
the face
here's tape of CNN earlier pour media
they built a whole imaginary industry
around Russian collusion desperately
expecting something huge that validated
their two-year efforts and emotions
their hearts careers and pocketbooks
rested on Trump being a Russian spy
right Brian the US president possibly
working for the Russians possibly an
unwitting pawn something the FBI was
investigating why are these leaks
happening and why are they happening now
what does Robert Mother know it was not
to be my little round fella the fantasy
of Trump as a Russian agent was just
that a fantasy now all they've got left
is more empty accusations the worst part
the media would have preferred that the
President had been a Russian stooge even
if it destroyed a country hence their
reaction today bill Barr has decided his
legacy he is fine with his legacy being
the AG who took one for the team it was
an extraordinary political commercial
for the president a real black mark on
his long and previously distinguished
career he blew it
he said precisely Jake what the
President of the United States wanted to
hear no collusion is this something that
we are supposed to see from the Attorney
General of the United States not the
Attorney General of the president of the
other day that's the entire CNN staff so
when your reality is a failure then the
fairy tale becomes reality
so it's analogy time remember to high
school you had a friend who got dumped
and it was the worst thing ever he
sulked and he wouldn't change his socks
for the rest of the school year he
couldn't let go but you a friend knew
you had to get him to move on so you
told him dude move on live your own life
so media I'm your pal
it's time to move on yeah you got dumped
and it hurts but clinging like this
makes you look weak and stupid
Vence growth new relationships new
obsessions new loves and there are other
stories out there what's great about
Trump a new story is like a bus you miss
one there'll be another in ten minutes
so cheer up press go to the gym ditch
the doughnuts make yourself presentable
because right now no one wants to be
with you not like this you're pitiful
pathetic even there's so many fish in
the sea
why not catch a real one this time so
Dana watching their reaction tells you
what would the outcome of benefit were
the opposite like how would they have
react I was thinking about that earlier
today like just well and also for us
yeah what if it would have been like to
be like whoa is enough and it would be
you know we would have been fair and
balan tell you what we wouldn't do we
wouldn't have 14 people who agree with
each other around a table it's seriously
do you think on the media there's
something interesting there were there
were some stories that turn out to be
true right so for all the stories where
they said President Trump is wanting to
fire Muller this weekend right well
turns out that's what bosses always do
okay I would have fired somebody every
day but there was a remember that
persistent rumor and it came up all the
time that Don junior expected to be
indicted
Don juniors telling friends he expects
to be indicted they act that doesn't
look like that could possibly be true I
don't know about that I am so excited to
talk about other issues ah I want to
stay on this all week then Jesse Jesse I
believe you have an analogy on deck I do
remember the movie The Fugitive yes
Richard Kimble yes [ __ ] kids
imprisoned chased yes he was innocent
and what did he do he eventually found
the real killer in this case for the
real killer is Hillary and Obama now
let's get back to what we were just
compared it to a movie plots that's not
an analogy okay see the analogy police
cut a heart shot sorry here's what I
think about the media now Muller was the
hero the hero did not deliver
so now Nadler becomes the hero but
Nadler isn't smart enough telegenic
enough trustworthy enough moderate
enough
smart enough anything to take the torch
from Muller and carry it across the end
zone he doesn't have anybody behind him
saying you know what you are the new
white knight at this point it looks like
the obstruction case is too thin for the
media to sell in a sexy way the audience
isn't going to love it the way they
loved collusion because it's too
confusing and they don't have anything
anymore and they're gonna have to move
on to something else
Murray can they move on they seem to me
like it bitter clingers oh I actually
think the molar report did deliver
I'm not underwhelmed by it I'm not heard
for Trump no Jesse's right it did not
that's not what it said you can keep
saying it over and over again but you
saying it doesn't make it true
there was no one charged with calamity
no one was charged with obstruction
never much neither movie Beetlejuice
when you just say Beetlejuice three
times what I want us to read this and we
can be disturbed by things in it with
what Russia did independent of the Trump
campaign with the things that Trump has
done like we can admit that as and we
don't have to just go to our corners
right our political corners we can read
it and say you know what if I was on a
presidential campaign I wouldn't have
done it that way I wouldn't have tried
to accept help from the Russians like
that's okay for Trump supporters to
admit I'm giving you permission I mean
all white thank you you got permission
the laundry got permission you agree
mother or I'm gonna invent the new
fallacy here this into it it's called
the negative information fallacy you're
conflating negative information against
the Trump team yes the report is not all
flattery all the time I get that people
make mistakes they're human but because
it's negative information again Murray
does not mean the Trump team committed a
crime no one was charged with those
crimes and I don't know why you can't
get past this there is no evidence of an
established connection in this collusion
that it is a fraud can you just like
take the loss on this and say I made a
big mistake I'm sorry to America I
should not have to do that based on this
report I don't think she should have to
do that you know and why shouldn't I
have to Dana because I do think that you
can read it and go WOW like that I think
I think the Democrats should say we
accept that there's no collusion and we
applaud and they said the president was
a true David I think that one should be
I think
could read that as a Democrat and read
the obstruction piece and go gosh this
is really terrible I read it as an
American and I'm economy our president
is not a spa I would agree with that
stupid he beat the pants off hill but
there was never a that's the problem
it's it was never evidence of collusion
ever all right this is too much fun I
think we should make the five three
hours today
just blow out those other shows